buenas tardes poco a poco miembros del
público y los turistas que están en
londres o en escocia han ido acercándose
a las residencias oficiales de la
familia real especialmente en balmoral
donde se encuentra la monarca de 96 años
el castillo de windsor que es el
favorito de la reina en las afueras de
londres y también en el palacio de
buckingham ubicado en el centro de la
capital británica para dejar flores y
mensajes de apoyo y fuerza para la
monarca que está enfrentando problemas
de movilidad no sabemos qué tal es el
estado de salud de la reina isabel
porque el palacio de bukingham entregó
detalles alarmantes dijo que los
doctores están preocupados por el estado
de la salud de la reina pero no tenemos
certeza exactamente cuál es el mal que
la queja como lo mencionaba la reina ya
está rodeada de su familia más cercana
pero también hace poco aterrizó un avión
de la fuerza armada real británica en
aberdeen en una de las puntas de escocia
transporta vía terrestre hasta el
castillo de balmoral a aproximadamente
una hora ya deben estar llegando al
castillo para poder acompañar a la
monarca en este momento tan difícil no
hay un nuevo parte oficial sobre el
estado de salud de la reina sobre su
evolución y solamente lo conoceremos de
manera oficial así que esa es la
expectativa por supuesto que se viene el
país donde hay un tipo de tristeza y
también de shock porque como lo
mencionaban ustedes hace apenas dos días
vimos a la reina así con problemas de
movilidad utilizando un bastón para
poder sostenerse un poco más delgada que
usualmente pero sonriendo así que esa es
la gran sorpresa y la expectativa que
gira en torno en este momento aquí en el
reino unido